the locker room locker room is brutal
you went to an athlete's school so I
feel like you guys are just you know
holding each other down and putting your
balls in each other's mouths there was
no
there was no locker room at school
because everyone played Sports outside
of school oh like we had no high school
teams it was just for people that were
like
you know had like we're on like the
Olympic skiing team and [__] like that
oh cool yeah what nice little Flex I
mean we did have some Olympic skiers oh
that's what the school is for yeah it's
for them and then the divers just kind
of snuck in God so that we'd have to go
to class pretty much got it yeah we're
like no diving's diving's legit too and
they're like okay we'll allow it yeah
and so the locker room I mean I've told
you this before but the locker room that
like at my pool that my team Dove at was
like it was like a public gym so it's a
gigantic locker room it was like
downtown Calgary it's like one of the
main gyms that people went to oh so
there's like old guys with their nuts
out yeah and there's the dude that was
the dude with the like his whole dick
was pierced right like barbells all the
way through his shaft right all the way
down insane image to see as a child oh
yeah I mean I was like a teen I was in
high school it's still pretty insane
image to see IR actually yeah at any age
yeah it's an insane image to see that
was like pretty scarring but yeah you
know you see a lot of [__] in public
locker rooms yeah a lot of old dudes
taint hair and stuff like that you know
pretty scarring for him too that I'm
just nice
yeah I think you know like when you saw
lemon party for the first time yeah you
could still go ah and mentally
disconnect right but if you see a
barbell old guy dick yeah you're like
whoa and then he's still there for a
while yeah that's true yeah and you
might see him again you can't really
yeah I guess you can't really switch
tabs in that scenario no not mentally
yeah no because then you could punch him
if he farts yeah
oh
hey dude Zack tap you just ow yeah
ow what do you have in here
brass [__]
that TSA must be hell for that guy yes
seriously
it's my [__]
you're watching that video of TSA like
feeling the guy's pocket he's like what
is this he's like that's my penis oh
sorry and then that cop as well remember
that old a cop just like completely
reaches around he's totally just
fondling the front of his [__] pants
he's like what's this right here he's
like that's my penis sir he's like
whoops sorry whoopsie just like mushing
yeah you know
just squeezing the tip yeah it's like
it's like he's like letting a dog like
sniff his inner palm and he's just like
itching the top of his head you know I'm
just picturing an [__] TSA agent to
the barbell guy he's like back back
through the scanner so it's my I have a
dick piercing he's like they gotta come
out oh no put him in the tray oh no I
said All Metals in the tray dick
piercing [__] piercing needs to come out
no shoes
like yeah screwing it yeah squeaking
it's just sorry I haven't taken these on
years and then and then he goes for a
piss in it
French
it's like one of those uh like lawn
sprinklers yeah like those hoses for
kids
[Laughter]
the guy like on the on the computer
looking at all the things just does like
that begrudging move where he grabs the
train just throws it yeah in there
please
you know on those body scanners they see
your [__] every time they'll see your
dick yeah I know
they don't sit they don't show it on the
screen that you see when it like has the
little red square yeah but inside they
can see your they can see the shape of
everything that's so they see your dick
every single time you go through that
that's cool yeah just so everyone knows
that yeah I've heard that before I just
chose not to believe it
now it's full on that that's cool yeah
yeah it's awesome I think it makes you
feel really good yeah myself same I
think it's awesome yeah well they're
like
when they started saying hands up and do
the [__] shame thing
laughs
sir hands up please hey like the picture
sir like the picture both hands up Sir
like the picture
yeah it starts to go around timing it
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know how you
did that but it worked
that sucks dude
I don't want people looking at yeah yeah
when when they're like stand right here
please just wait you know and they're
waiting for the screen but they also
have like little earpiece they're like
okay I'll tell them yeah you're good so
say hey I missed it I missed it oh sorry
you mind walking back through it for me
yeah yeah just humiliating you hold on I
didn't I didn't get a pick
I didn't take a picture of the screen
but I guess maybe the the good thing is
they don't see your face right
they don't see your face you know it's
just like in a non
I mean the people that are working there
see your face yeah but it's like uh you
know
the people in the office whatever's
looking at those images it's one of
those mutually assured you know privacy
things yeah maybe where they can't see
your face yeah and then the other people
can't see your [__] yeah that's true
pick your poison that is true the guy
next to me when I was you know back when
back when I did a show in Baltimore okay
airplane etiquette minus 100. it was a
early morning flights like 6 A.M
and you know they they time things out
right they do breakfast and then it's
lights down during lights down it's full
opens the window Oh no just a stare at
it dude that is like rule number one
it's like kind of read the room then you
just looking out the window oh
and you know I throw my hood on I'm like
this [__] yeah and then
lights up we're about you know we're an
hour out a little refresher wake up yeah
windows up lights up he closed window
down to go on his iPad
and I was like you [__] did you
play paper clips on your flight no no no
how are you doing on how you doing on
the clip let me check let me show you
maxed out I dude I'm a loser
that's how I feel when I play this
stupid monkey game are you still playing
yeah
I don't even call it by its name I just
call it monkey game you know you need to
have the app open to make progress so
like it's the same as last time it's
just kind of depressing I know I haven't
been I haven't been doing it I haven't
been tending to my Factory
you're sending to your Clips yeah I mean
it's kind of just on autopilot now it's
like a you know just passive income at
this point yeah you know you you know
you got to start up the business dude I
know
yeah
balloon AKA monkey game
you look like such a child are you
playing that on the plane yeah I just I
don't care anymore I just yeah um yep
yep
it's
I'm a child what can I say yeah I did I
did a show or did one of the shows in
Baltimore and then the last it's so
funny how my set has evolved it used to
be the last 25 minutes where like really
dark very uncomfortable stories for some
people to hear okay and then now it's
more like the last 10 to 15. okay you
know I don't I
I don't put people through as much but
uh one show people were kind of like
damn
and then I just
it sounded like I snapped but I was
trying to be funny but I was like so let
me enjoy go-karts [__] I didn't really
have a good child everyone's like yeah
go for it from yeah whatever you need
man
but now this ever since I said that I
like laugh I'm like damn I really am
just trying to have a childhood way too
late playing iPad games
racing go-karts all this [__] dude I did
it give a race car back yeah yeah I'm
doing it in reverse yeah